bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique une fois par mois ici en
plateau à guyancourt je reçois donc et
un élu après benoît hamon c'est
aujourd'hui elle david douillet lui
aussi est et député des yvelines
conseiller régional chef de file des
républicains dans le département il
apporte un soutien sans faille à nicolas
sarkozy qu'il espère voir remporter la
primaire de la droite et du centre avec
lui nous parlerons de l'actualité
politique mais aussi des principaux
sujets à la une des médias ces derniers
jours bonsoir david moyenne soit
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy est en train
de décrocher dans les sondages selon le
figaro il est autour de 30 %
d'intentions de vote sur le premier tour
contre 41% pour alain juppé est-ce que
tout est déjà joué
pliez noms font sur mon nom je pense pas
et c'est d'ailleurs paradoxal gens
disent qu'il est fière avec sur un
déplacement qu'on a pu faire avec
nicolas sarkozy à nancy et à metz il
sait pas ce qu'on vit sur le terrain
c'est très étonnant entre ce que les
sondages explique enfin la montre est ce
qu'on vit sur le terrain et pas
forcément sur des déplacements très
politique en tout cas ce que j'entends
des gens qui sont pas forcément hyper
politisé enfin voilà monsieur tout le
monde
c'est pas du tout ce que je ressens
c'est très étonnant donc à la ya un
décalage du mal à me l'expliquer entre
entre ce qui ce qui est révélé dans les
sondages est ce que les gens vous disent
très étonnant on verra bien à mon avis
je pense ça va être beaucoup plus serré
qu'on le dit et je pense aussi qu'on
n'est pas loin enfin je pense qu'on va
virer en tête
c'est mon avis personnel en tout cas la
stratégie en tout cas aujourd'hui c'est
tellement inquiet françois bayrou
soutien de dernière juppé d'attaquer le
centre françois bayrou qui représente ce
pôle stratégie on s'en serait bien passé
pourtant en ce moment les attaques se
multiplient contre françois bayrou et
7,7 à nyons à l'issue d'enchères je me
suis berrou s'est invitée dans la
campagne des couleurs de la droite alors
que ces dernières années il nous a
plutôt démontré qu'il était de gauche
donc moi ça me dérange pas franchement
j'ai ce que je respecte ces hommes qu'on
devrait une vraie colonne vertébrale à
benoît hamon et de gauche je le connais
je l'apprécient beaucoup voilà il n'y a
pas de problème je suis droitier droit
voilà demain benoît benoît va pas va pas
venir dans les rangs de de la primaire
de la droite pour dire que seulement
voilà évidemment et il aura raison
donc là quand quelqu'un qui a voté pour
françois hollande ou quelqu'un encore je
me souviens qu'ils aient pu voter dès ce
qu'on appelle des motions de censure
d'eau contre des gouvernements de droite
lorsqu'il était parlementaire
et là je parle du discours du vote des
motions de censure qu'il eut lieu après
le discours de fillon à l'assemblée ou
encore celui d'avant donc qui a voté
avec la gauche là je comprends plus je
comprends plus mais alain juppé
aujourd'hui explique que pour gagner de
toute façon et pour l'avenir du pays il
faut rassembler aussi plutôt vers le
centre plutôt que vers l'extrême droite
n'avait pour diriger un pays il faut
assembler c'était bidon bon mais de là
on est dans une primaire de la droite et
du centre
pas de la droite et du centre gauche de
jauge gauche voilà jusqu'à aujourd'hui
je suis désolé monsieur maillot et je
parle pas du reste du modem parce que
bon nombre d'entre eux et j'en connais
et en particulier ici dans notre
département ne sont pas d'accord avec ce
qu'a pu faire monsieur bayrou dans le
passé et ça c'est à noter
donc voilà quelqu'un qui ne refusent les
règles de la primaire en se disant
demain si c'est nicolas sarkozy qui
gagne je me présenterai donc voilà mais
si c'est alain juppé je me présente pas
donc il fait ce qu'il veut
voilà qui a fait passer la gauche en
2012 et ses stars il est il sain vie
personnelle invités et et puis on
s'étonne que bon soit pas l'accord ben
on n'est pas d'accord voilà il ce qui
choisit son camp une bonne fois pour
toute et qu'il accepte les règles une
bonne fois pour toutes on parlait de
cette primaire la primaire justement
votre sentiment est ce que la campagne
se déroule dans un climat plutôt serein
on assume ces relations tout de même à
des petites phrases de temps en temps
tellement ridicule ce bilan six ans
phrase les petites phrases mec moi de
l'intérieur sont plutôt dit parler les
2e 3e 4e couteau en général et tête de
liste en voit plutôt justement les
seconds couteaux
c'est pas le jeu le franchement le sujet
sérieux il s'agit m
il est fort à parier que celui qui donne
ma première devienne le prochain
président de la république
voilà sérieuses et jus de l'avenir la
france voilà et dieu sait si elle a
besoin
nous sommes occupés de son avenir à la
france j'aimerais qu'on évoque le cas de
jean frédéric poisson le député des
yvelines président du parti chrétien
démocrate qui est candidat à cette
primaire il est passé devant les
instances de votre parti pour ses propos
sur les lobbys sionistes qui influe les
choix et d'hillary clinton il s'est
excusé depuis
il n'a pas été élu par la haute autorité
pour la primaire de la droite est ce que
c'est une bonne chose ou est ce qu'il
fallait
l'exclure il s'est excusé bon ça va
tellement vite viens pas jeter
l'opprobre sur quelqu'un que je connais
bien en plus c'est un excellent
parlementaire
c'est un bon compagnon pour l'assemblée
nationale et aussi dans les élites en
tant que parlementaire une parole ont
pesé très tellement vite déraper il
s'est excusé
est-ce qu'on serait dans le seul pays on
n'a pas le droit d'avoir plusieurs
chance une seconde chance
ces frappes alors je ne serai pas de
ceux qui vont l'accuser ni l'accabler et
je suis content qu'ils puissent rester
un crime et on va l'écouter justement
revenir sur ses propos les espèces qui
la formule est d'appuyer écouter cet
incident a été assez largement fabriqué
en réalité il ya deux choses il ya les
mois que je comprends de la communauté
juive française qui réagit de manière
extrêmement inquiète
à chaque fois qu'elle entend revenir des
mots ou des termes par lesquels elle
peut se sentir concerné je comprends
c'est et moi et c'est ce qui a justifié
marie alphonse ce matin sur france info
mais il ya aussi la réalité politique
qui consiste à pouvoir quand on est
candidat à une élection en france
critiqué et on en a le droit
la politique de l'état d'israël quand on
considère que cette politique dont
certains si dans certaines circonstances
quand certaines formations politiques
sont au pouvoir en israël c'est plus
vrai que quand d'autres y sont mais la
dignité du peuple palestinien est aussi
pour moi un sujet de préoccupation parce
que c'est une heure des éléments de la
paix au proche orient
voilà ce que j'ai pointé si donc mes
collègues veulent avoir un débat il m'a
interpellé sur la politique des
etats-unis au proche-orient
allons-y si c'est pour toutes autres
formes de raisons débat n'aura pas lieu
il n'y a pas de débat d'ailleurs j'ai
enfin ils me connaissent vous êtes
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
jean-frédéric à ses idées elles sont
claires en tout cas je peux vous dire
qu'il est pas antisémite n'a pas du tout
simplement une critique par rapport à ce
que peuvent faire les états unis au
proche orient
moi aussi j'ai mon avis en tant que
parlementaires français je considère que
les états unis ont commis beaucoup
d'erreurs sur l'ensemble de ce
territoire
voilà mais concrètement que j'ai les
suivre à chaque fois que le général de
gaulle nous avait expliqué fait
comprendre qu'on était suffisamment
grand et fort et puissant pour et on n'a
rien prend progressivement intégrer
l'otan depuis lors on voit là ça
malheureusement le dernier gouvernement
et le président la république doit
montrer un petit peu l'inversé cinq
dernières années mais ça a été impulsé
sous nicolas sarkozy il ce rapprochement
avec les états unis aussi oui mais qu'on
se rapproche des états unis s'est pas
c'est pas le souci mais qu'on soit
respectée c'en est un autre
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus
respectés ni alors mis au niveau de
l'europe ni au niveau des états unis ça
c'était pas mes caractéristiques du
vallon de nicolas sarkozy bien le
contraire un dernier mot rapidement sur
jean frédéric poisson même si cette
cette affaire du lobby sioniste la page
est tournée
malgré tout depuis il a tenu d'autres
propos et il avait aussi précisé qu'en
cas d'un d'un deuxième tour entre alain
juppé par exemple et marine le pen
rien n'était joué pour lui qu'ils ne
voteraient pas forcément pouvoir juppé
et d'ailleurs les instances de votre
parti l'ont rappelé lui ont rappelé les
règles il faudra voter et se ranger
derrière celui qui sera désigné
j'imagine que vous partager la vie de
ces de ses instances mérite dessus mais
joue au delà de ça ça traduit tout de
même calme ça va être difficile de
rassembler après je n'ose pas imaginer
jean frédéric poisson est quelqu'un qui
une colonne vertébrale et à des règles
et une vraie conduite
donc il a accepté les règles départ je
ne vois pas se déjuger en co2 voilà en
tout cas changer d'attitude
donc je
qui à moi qui me le dise de home devant
moi en face et la chaux obligé d'acter
ça mais en tout cas en l'occurrence a
pas été le cas et j'espère on continue à
parler de l'actualité politique dans le
ed département et on va parler d'un
autre candidat qui est loin d'avoir des
bonnes relations avec nicolas sarkozy
vous allez pas me contredire c'est bruno
le maire tout de même bruno le maire qui
était en meeting à saint germain en laye
on revient sur ce meeting le reportage
de nicolas kirillovitch sur les images
divines une première nous allons arriver
au sommet quelles que soient les
difficultés parce que les français
veulent le renouvellement de la vie
politique de faire preuve de renouveau
bruno le maire veut garder le cap et
répète son message à l'envi depuis des
semaines un slogan est une marque de
fabrique également scandé hier par
l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture en
meeting à saint germain en laye et qui
semble ravir ses futurs électeurs à la
primaire je sais déjà ce qui me pousse à
aller vers bruno le maire puisque
j'exclus voter pour quelqu'un qui a un
casier judiciaire vierge
j'exclus de voter pour les sortants
puisqu'ils ont un bilan
le fait de porter une certaine éthique
pour moi c'est très important
un certain dynamisme une jeunesse et
l'envi de nouveaux éducation sécurité ou
encore économie le candidat à la
primaire a développé une partie de son
programme devant plusieurs dizaines de
ses partisans lui qui reste optimiste
malgré des sondages qui le placent loin
derrière encore les ténors du parti
beaucoup de gens me disent voilà on va
très bien pour vous mais on veut avoir
l'assurance que le nicolas sarkozy soit
battu donc on va voter pour alain juppé
je connais pas une bonne motivation pour
son vote
on doit voter pour un projet et pour une
personne qui porte ce projet pas contre
un homme ou contre une personne ce
deuxième déplacement dans les yvelines
en l'espace de quelques mois a permis
également au député de l'eure de mesurer
ses soutiens dans le département on a
aujourd'hui environ 1200 militants sur
le département ce qui fait une force de
mobilisation importante et on a
aujourd'hui à peu près 120 130 élus
locaux qui nous ont rejoint un certain
nombre de maires laurent bros philippe
benassaya bernard grouchko plusieurs
conseillers départementaux et régionaux
et donc on a une vraie force politique
et populaire qui permet de porter notre
candidat prochain grand oral pour bruno
le maire jeudi 3 novembre date du
deuxième débat de la primaire
david douillet invités du 7-8 politique
pour bruno le maire nicolas sarkozy est
un loup garou
il a déclaré j'ai sous-estimé à quel
point nicolas sarkozy est rejetée par
notre propre électorat dès qu'il s'est
déclaré ce fut le retour du loup garou
les gens ont choisi pour celui qui était
le mieux placé pour le battre alain
juppé un simon est ainsi monté et puis
moi je suis descendu dans les sondages
je pense pas que ce soit la meilleure
formule du monde
voilà là aussi on est dans les petites
phrases c'est l'illustration disais tout
à l'heure il ya des jeunes nous il ya
des loups garous on préfère a déjà du
mal y ait sur cette affaire là s'il est
des vieux losing bon bref
bon enfin les petites phrases elle n'a
aucune espèce d'importance boulot c'est
quelqu'un je connais bien c'est
quelqu'un de grande qualité s'il est un
loto aura besoin pour continuer à ce que
la france reste un grand pays
elle a été déclassé sa c5 ça c'est le
constat moi je constate aussi que bruno
a fait partie du gouvernement de nicolas
sarkozy paie d'ailleurs comme françois
fillon est bon donc on parlait de
j'entendais parler bien moi même j'en ai
fait partie tout le monde un bilan dans
ce gouvernement et tout le monde
s'extrait en disant voilà coucou perche
et maintenant on voit vue le toucher
non il faut être honnête on aura besoin
de toutes les qualités des uns et des
autres c'est pour ça que enfin je n'ai
pas de conseil à donner je suis pas là
pour ça mais franchement toutes ces
petites phrases n'ont pas leur place les
compétences de ces personnes là que
j'estime beaucoup de jupes et jusqu'à le
maire en passant par françois fillon
on en aura besoin voilà ce sont des gens
de qualité pour les fonctions d'état
david douillet nos poursuivants 7,8
politique avec à présent notre séquence
réalisée en partenariat avec le lycée
emilie de breteuil à montigny le
bretonneux
cette année les élèves de terminale es
du lycée milite breteuil à montigny le
bretonneux qui suivent une spécialité en
sciences sociales et politiques
s'expriment sur notre antenne ils vont
voter pour la première fois en 2010 est
donc pour la présidentielle pour les
législatives
je vous propose de les écouter il évoque
aujourd'hui notamment leur regard sur
les députés est-ce que je me sens
concernée par les législatives enfin
quand j'aurai quand on veut pouvoir
voter personnellement c'est difficile de
poser la question maintenant étant donné
que les législatives c'est enfin un
député on ne sait pas vraiment si il
sert vraiment pas nous représenter ou
pas on sait pas vraiment ce qui fait
nous on n'y eut ni ce qu'il dit ou bien
on voit pratiquement jamais et moi
j'aimerais bien savoir par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'il fait réellement les
sortent tous des mêmes écoles donc ils
ont à peu près tous étaient même si des
informations après ça change un petit
peu mais globalement c'est la même chose
après je pense que quand ils se
présentent eux y croient au minimum
leurs engagements mais après et comme
manque de recul je pense qu'ils
n'arrivent pas aller te dire
actuellement viable que des candidats de
plus de 60 ans auquel représenter la
jeunesse c'est pas top ils savent que
s'ils disent vraiment ce qu'ils vont
faire
quand ils vont et élus ils n'auront pas
beaucoup de chances d'être élu ils vont
dire
déjà ils vont tenir des promesses qu'ils
savent très bien qu'ils ont passé mais
moi je vois un peu comme des
carriéristes
enfin les grands hommes politiques je
veux dire pas forcément au niveau
municipal
mais dès qu'on arrive aux législatives
aux présidentielles fin par exemple pour
moi les les députés ils sont là nous
aurons les voix pendant la campagne
après avoir seulement s'ils ont d'autres
places ou une meilleure opportunité ils
vont la saisir j'irai voter pour
quelqu'un que je sais qu'il ya des
vraies solutions en fait qui explique
bien ces solutions est qui et qui
réussit à les développer correctement et
non à dire oui je vais baisser le
chômage mais sans rien dire à côté et en
ne formulant aucune aucune réponse
concrète
je voterai pour quelqu'un voilà qui a
des promesses solide c'est assez
inquiétant malgré tout ce qu'on a
entendu de la famille est celle de
terminale on les a pas orienté sommes
allés les voir et ils se sont exprimés
ils n'ont pas du tout confiance envers
leur politique la représentant
franchement vous et moi à l'orage est ce
que nous on n'aurait pas on aurait
peut-être bon c'est très jeune en fait
c'est normal ils ont quand même voté
pour la première fois ils ont été assez
présent tati fraudé le fisc à l'orage
c'est bien cultiver oui pense à peu près
la même chose mais bon alors c'est
différent parce qu'ils me voient
travailler ici puisque c'est un député
pourquoi et à quoi il sert mais d'abord
une on sort pas tous de la même école
j'en suis forcément voilà pas fait une
école de députés milena né voilà moi
j'ai fait l'école de la vie ce qui est
pas la meilleure mon avis 2 un député
sert à quelque chose parce que il comme
le comme les sénateurs ils fabriquent la
loi et il sert à amender c'est-à-dire à
améliorer ou contrôler ou vérifier que
les propositions les projets de lois du
temps gouvernement coïncide bien avec ce
qui se passe dans la vraie vie
bon et puis troisième chose lorsqu'un d
un député développe son programme est
bien
après vous pouvez vous pouvez le suivre
il ya des cibles pour ça et puis si la
députée vous prêt mais qui promet qu'il
fera baisser le soma le chômage vérifiez
bien que lorsqu il votera pour la
réforme du code du travail il soit bien
là qu'il le fasse vraiment parce que le
chômage peut être déçu tout de suite moi
je le dis là ici en direct sur ted et
fils sont 18
s'il ya une vraie réforme du code du
travail nos artisans n'attendent que ça
et nos pme aussi est importé ni je
considère qu'un parlementaire pour qu'il
soit efficient et efficace et une vie
avant voilà qu'on ne fasse pas que de la
politique dans sa vie moi même j'ai eu
une autre vie avant
j'ai été chef d'entreprise aussi et
maintenant je suis parlementaire j'ai
une expérience de ce qu'ils demandent
justement plus de représentativité en
tout cas et on en revient sur sur un
autre sujet qui a été abordé dans
l'actualité récemment c'est ce manque de
représentativité puis le sentiment que
les politiques sont coupés du terrain
est forcément je vais vous emmener sur
cette déclaration sur cette réponse de
jean-françois copé sur le prix des pains
au chocolat par exemple parce que c'est
une bonne illustration est ce que ça
peut servir d'exemple pour dire regardez
les politiques sont coupés de la réalité
franchement j'ai fait un test auprès de
ma femme je lui ai demandé combien
valait 1 kilo de poireaux est incapable
de me répondre
elle connaissait le bruit de son caddie
par contre voilà donc tout ceci c'est
voilà ces sites du journalistique
manqueront comme il faut qu'on arrête
avec ça en revanche être connecté à la
vie c'est quoi ces êtres c'est connaître
les citoyens leurs problématiques et les
députés en général sont ce qu'on appelle
ddd asut le mot m'échappe
enfin reçoivent du public avec des gens
qui ont un certain nombre de problèmes
et c'est une permanence à traiter des
permanences gardien et merci beaucoup
un député aussi comme moi ce que je fais
rassemble chaque tous les deux mois peu
près en moyenne
l'ensemble des élus de son territoire
pour connaître aussi leurs problèmes
indique que les maires y compris un
député si c'est mon avis on se coupe
d'une information si on va jusqu'au bout
du non cumul des mandats on peut on pour
moi on devrait pouvoir cumuler un
certain nombre de mandats par rapport
aux tailles de mandat partenaires être
maire et député c'est possible oui mais
ça dépend de quel type de mairie de
l'ata et sega tout est une histoire de
temps et du temps qu'on a dans une
journée
voilà et ça faut le cadrer on peut
l'encadré la taille de deux villes
d'agglomération et ses stars puisqu'il
ya ça aussi qui rend toquero qui est
entré dans le jeu aujourd'hui mais je
serai plus infâme du non cumul dans le
temps voilà on pourrait s'imaginer qu'un
maire aucun député ne fasse que demanda
et puis laisse la main on pourrait
imaginer aussi qui est un peu moins de
députés et sénateurs
pourquoi pas on pourrait imaginer que
quelqu'un puisse se présenter à une
campagne afin un poste d'élu que s'il a
fait dix ans d'activité professionnelle
en dehors du giron politique ce serait
aussi ne pas une mauvaise idée à mon
avis voilà bon tout cela conférerait ce
que les parlementaires à ce que les
hommes politiques soient est connu la
vraie vie est soit beaucoup plus
pertinent sur ces sujets pour assurer
nos jeunes téléspectateurs l'étudiant on
va passer à la dernière séquence de
cette édition où on va évoquer le
quelques sujets d'actualité auparavant
puisque jean françois copé a eu droit à
sa question sur les pains au chocolat
nicolas sarkozy j'ai lu récemment sur
les chouquettes aussi le prix d'un
croissant le prix d'un poisson c'est le
prix d'un chocolat ça peut ça dépend des
régions à bourg-en-bresse on paye à 0 80
centimes qui savent que je mange un peu
là en région parisienne on met autour
d'un mur auteur d'un 9 bonnes réponses
basel pour les court courriers en tout
cas il ya une chose qui est sûre il ya
trop de beurre dedans c'est comme ça
qu'on les aime
on passe à la dernière séquence donc de
cette demi heure on parle de l'actualité
d'un sujet beaucoup moins saurions pour
le coup des migrants la question des
migrants riel démantèlement actuellement
de la jungle à calais au-delà de ça dans
les yvelines il ya l'accueil de ces
migrants des réfugiés qui posent et qui
oppose beaucoup de personnes il ya
beaucoup de contestations et c'est ce
que j'allais dire vous en faites partie
je fais partie
vous en tant que député vous vous
opposez à l'arrivée de ces migrants sur
le secteur et la housse est en
discussion actuellement avec la
préfecture juin peut-être au concours
est le sien oui bien moi on passe en
force
c'est ça qui me pose un problème on
passe en force
on demande pas l'avis de ceux qui
justement connaissent leurs populations
et le terrain voilà on va imposer des
gens à des populations qui sont pas
préparés peut-être ou en tout cas adapté
ou formatée ou en tout cas oui préparer
pour les recevoir
donc on va créer quoi écoutons les
maires écoutons les élus de de proximité
on nous écoute pas oui voilà monsieur le
maire vous allez en avoir tant vous vous
allez en important et vous vous allez en
noir temps c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
mais si on écoute chaque mère chaque
maire va plutôt se tourner vers une
réponse négative à refuser la carrière
des migrants donc ces migrants on en
fait quoi le problème
parce que c'est en général pas chez moi
mais chez le voisin c'est plutôt là
c'est bien tard mais le on est là où on
va essayer de répondre à une question
alors que la question se pose au départ
en réalité pourquoi avons-nous des
migrants et comme on les gère comment
ils viennent comment sont ils arrivés
jusque là où vont-ils ou veulent t'ils
vivre c'est ça la vraie question
en réalité c'est pas de ce qu'on va en
faire là maintenant on va faire ce qu'on
peut
sauf qu'il se vit d'amendé la france est
un pays une terre d'accueil
entre ceux qui sont là pour des raisons
de sauver leur peau des raisons
politiques et ceux qui sont la porte par
opportunisme ou par ils se sourient ils
se sauvent la vie aussi de certains
états ou le pauvreté extrême et bien
voilà ils sont aussi leur peau d'une
certaine manière
pis certains sont très opportuniste dans
cette affaire là bon pour trier tout ça
c'est compliqué sajid humain voilà
l'humain c'est sacré quelle que soit la
couleur de la peau quelle que soit la
provenance d'un individu et il faut les
respecter en tant que tel mais est-ce
que le premier respect d'un individu
s'est pas de lui expliquer ou de leur
faire comprendre que
on n'est pas en capacité de les
accueillir est-ce que c'est respecter un
individu de le prendre et pas savoir
quoi en faire
est-ce que là pour ça mais qui peut être
fait en amont autres on est d'accord son
travail qui peut être fait en amont mais
aujourd'hui concrètement comment on fait
pour ces réfugiés qui sont là les
migrants qui sont là aujourd'hui en
france on les accueille où on est mais
dans quel centre
quelles solutions on leur propose on les
renvoie chez eux alors qu'ils risquent
leur peau vous l'avez dit vous-même bat
pas tous à tous et c se et c'est ce
travail là qu'il faut faire pour savoir
qui est qui bon je vous rappelle que
dans les migrants peuvent se cacher
aussi un certain nombre de radicaliser
violent on est bien d'accord
vous savez ça quand même oui mais là
c'est mort we do mais aussi ce qu'on
entend pour ce faire il faut se rappeler
de manière aussi mon nom et celui de la
vérité c'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont
les services de renseignement voilà
c'est tout c'est pas moi qui le dis
aujourd'hui le premier de travail à
faire ce travail de même si le mot n'est
pas mais ils ont pris un bon mot pas du
tout ne va pas l'utiliser d'ailleurs
mais en tout cas on veut savoir qui on a
fait pourquoi
et à partir de là il faut aider aider
les mères leur demander combien de
personnes sont ils en capacité
d'accueillir dignement
mais ce travail là il n'est pas fait
bien sûr qu'on va les accepter
bien sûr qu'on va les états unis sont là
ces pauvres gens et bien cela le traité
mais discutons avec les élus pour
justement que l'accueil soit fait dans
de bonnes conditions que s'il ya des
volontés de s'implanter ici en france ça
se fait dans de bonnes conditions
mais surtout il faut arrêter il faut
arrêter l'hémorragie
parce qu'on n'est pas en capacité
aujourd'hui les accueillir si on avait
le plein emploi
si on avait les moyens mais aucun
problème bien au contraire
le premier je vous dis mais c'est pas là
c'est pas vrai c'est mentir un dernier
sujet est ce qu'on va arriver à la fin
de cette émission ces policiers qui sont
en colère aujourd'hui ils ont été reçus
par le gouvernement il ya eu des
annonces sur des moyens qui seront qui
seront débloqués pour autant on n'a pas
le sentiment que leur colère peu peu
s'apaiser
vous leur dites corps policier
aujourd'hui à moi à titre personnel que
je les soutiens à 1000% que leurs envies
leurs revendications légitimes que le
gouvernement sous-estiment réellement
les conditions dans lesquelles ils
travaillent que les moyens ne sont pas
au rendez vous compte tenu de ce qui
s'est passé je suis désolé pas quand on
quand le ministre de l'intérieur en est
à traiter de de sauvageons dire que
voilà sont des gens que c'est un
sauvageon quelqu'un qui cassent les
vitres d'une voiture et qui ensuite
jettent des cocktail molotov pour brûler
des gens qui sont à l'intérieur
moi j'appelle ça des criminels pas des
sauvages ont donc rien que ça veut
expliquer peut expliquer la la la
réaction de des policiers mais du côté
de la gauche on explique aussi qu'il ya
eu des réductions de budgets qui sont
faites sur le précédent gouvernement et
le précédent gouvernement c'est celui de
nicolas sarkozy la suppression aussi de
la police de proximité par exemple parce
que tout ça ça a été la région la police
de proximité par qui qui est supprimé ça
la police devant la question la police
de proximité en l'occurrence elle est
gérée par qui bat des moeurs très bien
se passer a dit maman qui supprime la
police au cours duquel sarkozy a soutenu
la police de proximité c'est assez
favorable à ce que cette police de
proximité des courts plus beau mais là
considérés efficaces c'est la compétence
d'un maire et du numérique
vrai ou pas la police municipale par
rapport à la question nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui vous aujourd'hui vous dites
c'est toujours été de ce jeu me de
jugement j'ai toujours été de ceux qui
ont toujours estimé qu'il ne fallait pas
toucher
en tout cas aux forces de sécurité pour
ce qu'ils agissaient d'abord de
l'allergie la réduction des
fonctionnaires
bon je le sais parce que moi même ma
famille j'ai des fonctionnaires fin
j'avais des fonctionnaires ont gelé tout
droit vers des fonctionnaires prison je
connais bien problème ils me font les
remontées du terrain dans tous les cas
au delà des humains il ya aussi des
moyens matériels à préserver
il ya aussi une gestion aussi de là
du nombre de policiers sur le terrain
c'est que j'ai un exemple qui avec une
augmentation des effectifs
on a quand même sur certains territoires
des services notamment le week-end qui
sont très compliquée à mettre en place
moi j'ai fait une un démarrage de
week-end avec le ddsp directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique
c'est quasiment faut quasiment une boule
de cristal
il ya des services de renseignements
pour savoir où positionner cette force
parce qu'il n'a pas assez poids qui quoi
qu'on fasse aujourd'hui même si les fx
qui va être décuplée conclure mais
honnêtement où il découvrait sarkozy
vous soutenez la mise en place d'un plus
grand nombre de policiers ils auront
plus de moyens pour la police
épisode 7 7 milliards mais les
propositions merci david douillet on va
désormais cette émission est trop court
toujours trop court nous refermons ce
7,8 politique rendez vous fin novembre
sur ce plateau mais d'ici là le 11
novembre au parlement européen le 7 8
politique qui part vous le savez
maintenant une fois par mois à la
rencontre
la de vos élus qui siègent à bruxelles
ou à strasbourg au rendez-vous préparé
par nicolas kirillovitch à très bientôt
sur tf1